M1: Yesterday, I played a news clip for you from
Monday in which Republican House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy staged a propaganda photo
op sort of event at the US Mexico border.
F3: And at this event, he claimed without
any evidence that Turkish, Iranian and Yemeni
terrorist undocumented immigrants were coming
over to the United States by physically and
illegally crossing the Mexico land border with
the US. Here is Kevin McCarthy saying it as I
played for you yesterday. Let's review the clip.
M7: And we you go to Monument three and you talk
to those agents. It's not just people from Mexico
or Honduras or El Salvador. They're now finding
people from Yemen, Iran, Turkey, people who are
on the terrorist watch list. They are catching
and they're rushing it all at once.
F3: Now, as I mentioned yesterday,
there is no evidence of that, but it sounds really
damn good and scary. So Republicans have taken
off with it. And this is quite literally what we
mean by Meems. It is a meme that has caught on.
And yesterday on FOX News,
Republican Congressman John CatCo
said the exact same thing. And it is spreading
and it is becoming in the absence of sort of like
real stories that Fox News wants to substantively
cover. They are just grasping at straws,
as we talked about yesterday, council
culture, Dr. Seuss, Potato Head, Joe Biden's
55 days without a press conference, this
type of thing. Now they've glommed on to
this. Take a listen to what CatCo had to say.
F7: Listen to the migrants that are crossing
that there might be other bad actors
and possibly even terrorists. What did
you hear from Border Patrol yesterday?
M8: Well, it was a stunning revelation,
to be honest with you. We were at the edge
of where New Mexico, Mexico and Texas meet,
and it's called Monument three. We're sitting up
on a bluff and we're asking the agents out there
on the front lines. And by the way, there is a
big gap in the fence there because of because
they stop construction. But when I talk to one of
them was telling us what they were seeing coming
across the border, they saw over 100 people
come across in the last few days and that
one little sector. And he said some of them
are on the list. And I said list? And he said,
yeah, the terror watch list. I was stunned and
I've never heard that before. They said they've
seized not just people from Central and South
America, but even people from Yemen and places
in the Middle East that are terrorism hotbeds.
So the claim is that people on the terrorist
watch list from the Middle East are crossing the
land border between the U.S. and Mexico. Now,
is it possible that this could happen? Of course,
yeah, it could happen. It is conceivable that
a suspected known terrorist from Iran could
get themselves to Mexico and then cross over
the border, you know, in the middle of the desert
that that could happen up. Friend of the show and
former David Pakman show guest, Congressman Ruben
Gallego is on the Subcommittee on Intelligence and
Special Operations. He represents Arizona, a
border state. So he would know something about
this. And he tweeted, quote, Weird as the chairman
of the Subcommittee on Intelligence and Special
Operations and a border state member of Congress.
Haven't heard anything about this. Going to ask
for a briefing. Pretty sure he is either wrong or
lying. And the congressman went on to say, high
Republican leader meeting Kevin McCarthy. I have
the same security clearance as you do. Can you
have your office arrange for a classified briefing
for members to see where this info derived from
Customs and Border Patrol was asked about this?
They haven't commented. And the truth is that this
is just an old lie that is being refreshed. Once
again. Donald Trump told this lie in 2019. Donald
Trump told this lie in January of this year before
leaving office. He said, quote, We have terrorists
from the Middle East coming into our country
through the southern border. And he also mentioned
it last night at the earlier in the show, we
covered this very strange interview that Donald
Trump gave last night to Maria Bartiromo. And this
was one of the topics that came up. Donald Trump
again made this claim A, they're coming in.
M2: You take a look. They're coming in
from all foreign countries. I see
they're coming in now from Yemen.
They're coming in from the Middle East. They're
coming in from everywhere. They're dropping
them off and they're pouring into our country.
F3: If it's happening, it should be dealt with and
taken seriously. But there is still no evidence
that people on the terrorist watch list from Iran,
Yemen and Turkey are going to Mexico and then
illegally crossing over to the United States. Now,
if you're going to say, well, David, if they're
doing it illegally, we don't know. We can't
we can't say for sure. We don't know that it's
happening, but we can't say that it's not. Well,
that's an indefeasible statement, that that would
be as as plausible as me saying, you know, there
are people from. Australia going to Argentina,
renting a motorcycle and driving all the way north
and then riding the motorcycle through the desert.
You can't say it's not happening. Well, then what
are we talking about here? At some point we have
to say, what is the evidence that this is going
on? So this was actually floating around during
the Obama years. And it's important to remember
just this one data point that the Saudis who
did 9/11 came to the United States legally with
visas. They took flight lessons at American flight
schools. You know, all of this different stuff.
Why smuggle yourself in through the southern
border? Why even send people already on the watch
list, which could only attract attention? It makes
no sense. It doesn't even pass the sniff test.
And I actually am wondering, has there
been any terrorist attacks on U.S. soil
who came from the Middle East over the US Mexico
border illegally? I look, I spent some time this
morning looking. I wasn't able to find a single
example of any wrongdoer, I guess is the term
assailant. I don't know what term you
want to apply, who did what is being
alleged here? Not a single example. And I by all
means, if you find one, let me know and I will
issue an update or a correction. Call it what you
will. But yet another completely imagined story,
which as of yet is not supported
by any evidence whatsoever